hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
titled best practices for lot changes in
quality control
or reagents i'm susie valdez of
labyrinths and i will be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
sponsored by bio rad laboratories
now i want to invite everyone to
participate by submitting your questions
during this presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
located on the far left of your screen
and click send
any questions we do not answer during
the webinar will be captured and
responded through the q a list
that will be posted next week in the
event resources box
which is located below the ask a
question box
now you'll find a short handout with a
summary of today's guidelines there and
you'll be also
able to download the presentation
handouts once the webinar is available
on demand
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation just submit
those concerns through the ask a
question box and we will address those
issues
now as a reminder this presentation is
educational and offers
free continuing education credits so
click on the continuing education
credits tab
located on the top right corner of your
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain those
credits so let's get started today's
webinar
on best practices for a lot changes in
quality control or reagents
consists of two presentations and a q a
session at the end the first
presentation will focus
quality control lot changes so today i
now present today's
first speaker mr nico vendepole
nico works as a scientific and
professional aid
affairs manager at the quality systems
division of bio rad laboratories in
irvine california
he studied clinical chemistry in belgium
and worked
both the diagnostic and research
laboratories before he started
at biorad nico works to promote an
understanding of laboratories regulation
and best practices
as they return to qc and eqapt programs
for complete biography of mr vanderbilt
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
niko welcome you may now begin your
presentation sir
thank you susie for that nice
introduction and
good morning to everybody welcome to
this
webinar on best practices for lot
changes in quality controls or reagents
so just to introduce the learning
objectives so hopefully after today's
presentation
you will be able to identify how you can
establish the new mean and standard
deviation for your new lots
you will also be able to describe the
new simplified clsi
c24 guidance to perform the crossover
studies
and you will be able to explain how to
use qc and patient specimens
to verify the integrity of a new reagent
lot
so for the first part of the
presentation i wanted to talk to you how
to perform
the quality control crossover studies so
we all know
that when we're running quality controls
we have all our different products
available in the lab unfortunately they
don't
last forever so there's expiration dates
and there's a time
that we're gonna have to start with a
new lot the manufacturer makes the new
product
and again same thing there because
there's sometimes up to 100 analytes
in a control the targets cannot be the
same
exactly every time so we need to
establish the new targets again we need
to know what should be our range
that we can accept and we need to do
that for each of these different
lot materials so
when we look at qc crossover studies
we'll take a quick look
what the current process is what most
labs are still doing today
and then we have the question can we
simplify this crossover studies
and i've based a lot of this
presentation
on the clsi c24 guidance
the the for the fourth edition and
so that is the statistical quality
control for quantitative measurement
procedures
principles and definitions so if you
would read that document
you would find a lot of these things a
lot of these guidelines
and i just put them a bit together and
made it a bit easier for us to follow
through
so if we now take a look at what we
currently do for our qc crossover
studies
so what you see here visually is that we
always have to establish our own mean
and standard deviation for control
material we need to do that in the lab
because every instrument is different
every
procedure that we work on the instrument
is a bit different lab by lab
so that means that our new lot of
control material
should be analyzed in parallel with a
lot of the control material that we
currently have in use
and for today and what i hear most in
the labs
is that every has that magical number
20. so what we normally do is
over 20 days we collect 20 data points
of results
so we still use our current lot in use
to
do our evaluation of our instrument
and then at the same time we start
running our new lot
once we get to 20 data points we then
normally calculate the mean
and the standard deviation from those 20
data points
and then we move forward with that data
so we can continue and we have that data
established and we have a valuable mean
and standard deviation it's very
difficult and almost impossible
to say okay today i'm ending with my
current lot tomorrow i start with the
new lot
but i just start like that without any
information
then your first result that comes in is
is an unknown what if that first result
was a failure or was something that
wasn't really in control
we would never know until maybe one or
two days later
so that's why we establish those targets
so let's break it up and so we have two
things we have our mean
and we have our standard deviation so
let's start
on how we can determine our new standard
deviation for our new lot
and it's actually pretty easy to start
with that
because what is the best standard
deviation to use
that is actually our current standard
deviation that we've
measured over an extended period of time
so our current load that we've been
using for a year
maybe year and a half or two years that
is actually the best possible estimation
of our imprecision of our system
because it includes a lot of the events
that can influence our imprecision
and so i listed a couple of them here
for example that could be
different operators uh environmental
factors like temperature humidity
reagents and reagent loss changes
different calibration calibration cycles
even calibrator look
changes might all be part of that
and also maintenance preventive
maintenance and other things
that we do on the instrument so
actually the first part is almost
already finished
so how do we determine our standard
deviation for our new lot
it's actually we just take the standard
deviation of our previous lot
so that is really simple we don't really
have to calculate that standard
deviation anymore from 20 data points
we just take the current one because
that's actually a lot better and a lot
more
uh stable and reflective of the
performance of our instrument
then when we would calculate something
with just 20 data points
from our new one but that's the first
part but i also want to give you some
more
tips and tricks here on uh what we have
to do with that standard deviation and
what we have to be careful for
so one of the things that i wanted to
show is that when we talk about the
standard deviation standard deviation is
always
expressed as an absolute value and
when our new target mean is close to our
current target mean then you could take
your standard deviation as an absolute
value and move that over
but if that target changes a little bit
we have to be careful that we don't use
the standard deviation
but it's actually then better to use our
coefficient of variation
or cv to fix that new imprecision target
so i put an example in here so you can
see on the left
if our current control has a mean of 120
units whatever they are with a standard
deviation of five
so then we calculate that that's a 4.16
cv
so if our new control
material has a mean of 142 units
if we would just copy over the standard
deviation of five
we're now actually changing our targets
we're changing our cv
to 3.52 so what actually happens is that
by moving over our current standard
deviation as an absolute value
we would be setting a different uh
imprecision target
and and that's not really what we want
because we want to make sure that we
have the same
so it is better to copy over that cv
value
of 4.16 and then we can recalculate
the standard deviation and so here for
this control
if our new control material would be at
a mean of 142
it would be better to change your
standard deviation to 5.9
so that's the first one what is also
important is that
sometimes you might have control
materials that don't last very long
that have a shorter shelf life maybe
only a couple of months
and when you then want to use the
standard deviation or the cv
from that one control material it isn't
that strong because it's a shorter
period of time
and there is actually a formula and this
is this pooled formula
where you can take standard deviations
or cvs
from multiple previous lots and you can
combine them together
to calculate an overall standard
deviation or cv
and so this is this pooled formula um
the most important part for this pooled
formula is that
we have the number of data points which
are part of this pooling
because otherwise if we would just be
taking our
mean of multiple lots it could be that a
lot that was very short
within would have an influence in
changing our standard deviation so this
is why
we have the the n in there or the number
of data points that are in there
so using a pooled standard deviation
formula can help us
to get a better long-term estimate of
that standard dph
another thing that sometimes can happen
is that throughout the life of a quality
control
sometimes we might have a shift or a
trend
or something that changes our targets a
little bit and i put in here
a levi jennings chart that shows you
that
somehow here there was a reagent lot
change or a calibrator lot change
and our targets shifted up a little bit
so they're a bit different
well if you have something like that it
is also interesting
to use that uh pooled formula
or to maybe just use one part of this
imprecision target for this formula so i
show it to you
as an example here so for example
here you see on the left in that blue uh
window
that we had a reagent load a which had a
mean
of 15 units with a standard deviation of
one
so that comes to a cv of 6.6 and we had
100 data points
and then we changed to a reagent or a
calibrator little b
and our mean changed a little bit so you
can see that our target went from 15
to 17 and so now we're at the standard
deviation still of 1.1
and a cv of 6.5 so you can see that the
instrument still works at the same
imprecision
we just have a little change in that
target
and we had 150 data points for that
latest law
so if you would take all these data
points together 250 data points and
calculate the standard deviation
or the cv you would actually get a
standard deviation here of 1.44
or a cv of almost nine percent so again
what you would see
is that although the instrument works at
6.5 6.6 percent cv
by having that shift we can actually get
a difference
sd or cv which would increase or or
target or limit
and so that would be dangerous to miss
significant uh
changes so using a calculated or a
pooled
sd will give you that value of 1.06 or a
cv of 6.5
which is the target we want to keep
using
here you could also use actually the cv
of for example the last part
of our load that load b that's 6.5 that
would work too
so another suggestion is don't use the
insert value range
or any analytical performance
specification as your own working
standard deviation or cv
when you look at insert ranges they are
based on a population of instruments
and they are too wide normally for an
individual instrument
so if you look at an insert and you find
your target
and your range is there that is where
your mean
that you establish in your lab should
fall it should fall within that range
but then you should use your own
standard deviation
to protect that value or to control that
value
and i've seen several labs where
they would look at the insert for
example and the insert says okay my
target is 100
and the range goes from 80 to 120
well if you would take that 80 and 120
as your limits of your ranges
and you would fix that and now your
target
would be 90 you are running your control
and you find 90 units
then what happens is that on the lower
side of your control you would only have
10 units that you can move
but on the top side of your control you
actually have 30
which would be probably way too wide and
you would have significant statistical
changes going up
that you wouldn't detect if you would
just use those insert ranges
i've also seen labs that would take both
ranges
and then look how much difference there
is between the target
and the upper and lower range and then
they would divide that by
two or by three and fix that as their
standard deviation
again that should not be how we set our
standard deviation ourselves in the lab
we should use our own
instrument standard deviation and
establish that value and use that value
analytical format performance
specifications
targets like biological variation or
clia limits
they are clinical performance targets
most of the time
and so using those might give you a
feeling of being in control and having
good performance
but often they're they're a little wider
and so
they might be missing statistical
relevant changes
so most of these analytical performance
specifications are there to help you
when you have a failure on your
instrument to see if it would also
affect the clinical
performance of your instrument of your
results and
they're not really there to be used as a
target by themselves
so there too again establish
use your own standard deviation or your
own cv
also don't use an interlab comparison
group
standard deviation so that is the same
thing as we discussed
peer group standard deviation they will
reflect a variation of
all the participating instruments
combined but there's also a bias
component in there
and that doesn't reflect the individual
instrument performance
so i made another example here in that
blue area
you can see three labs that participate
in an interlab program they all send in
20 data points
but you can see that their targets are a
little different
so the first lab finds 105 milligram per
deciliter then 115
and the other 120. but they all have the
same standard deviation of five so you
can see that their cvs
are very close to each other if you
would
put these three labs together in one
peer group
what's going to happen well you can see
here that the mean of the peer group
would be 113 but that standard deviation
is 7.9 almost 8 or a cv of 7
so again you would see that the cv of
the peer group is
wider because you have that variation of
those different results in there
so again you wouldn't be using that
seven as your target
but you need to use your own target
which would be here
like a 4.3 or a 4.7 from each of those
labs
there is a place in your unity reports
your unity interlab reports
there is one report which is called the
statistical profile report
where you can actually go see all the
distribution
of those individual cvs of all the
instruments participate
and that is something which could give
you some information and some guidance
on okay how well am i doing am i nicely
finding the same cv as the other labs or
am i a bit better or a bit worse
but again it isn't the aim to use that
as your target
but it can give you information of how
all your other
participants in your peer group are
performing so it can help you a little
bit but again
establish your own target in your lab
so that was for the standard deviation
so actually i gave you a lot of tips and
and some guidance there but
it's pretty straightforward for your
standard deviation we just use whatever
we already had for our existing material
so now we're moving forward now we have
to establish our mean
we need to establish our target what is
our correct value
and so there again according to the clsi
guideline
it becomes a little easier because we
can use 10 measurements on separate
dates
so not the 20 anymore but just 10.
and if you do 10 data points on 10 days
try to include a calibration event or a
couple if you can
because also those are the points that
introduce a little bit of that variation
for your results
also try to use the same qc vial
frequency as in your daily routine
so sometimes if you would just have to
do 10 measurements
you would probably just use one vial of
qc material and run that
for 10 days but if throughout the day
if throughout your normal routine you
would normally use
more qc or you would be running it on
other instruments and so normally every
two days for example you would be using
a new vial
then try to do the same thing for your
crossover
for some of the controls for example a
lyophilized control where you have to do
a reconstitution that is important that
you see a little bit of that variation
while you're doing your crossover so try
to mimic that
that routine that daily routine
also make sure that if something happens
with the instrument and your current lot
is showing you that there's an out of
control condition
then don't accept the new lot
results so reject that and just add one
more data point
once the instrument is back in control
or just do
another one the next day or go a day
longer to establish your crossover for
that
again as a couple of pointers like i
like we also said for the standard
deviation don't use
the insert value the insert value are
provided as a guideline
and you should establish and verify your
own targets
why is that important because
you have to make sure that when a target
is set
by a manufacturer and other laboratories
that
help you to set that often they will be
using a different
reagent load or a different calibrator
look so those targets might always be a
little bit different
so make sure that you establish your own
targets by yourself and don't just copy
an insert target value
if a target value needs to be
established more quickly
if you're running out of other material
you're a little later you could also go
and do a couple
more results a day but remember the more
you speed that up
the more you're starting to remove the
variation
of those different um steps in there
and that could give you an optimized or
a little better target than you would uh
want
but for the mean actually it is
less of an issue than for the standard
deviation
so you could speed it up a little bit if
you would want again
just make sure you plan everything out
nicely make sure you have your 10 days
to run
your uh your new lot
another one don't use the interlab
comparison peer group mean
so again it's the same thing like i
already said before
these values aren't really an individual
instrument value
so as you can see here on that little
distribution chart
it is a normal distribution of results
that comes in
not every instrument has exactly the
same result and it doesn't mean
that you are more correct or you are
less correct if you're a little bit next
to that target
if your peer group is 120 and you're at
117
your instrument can be working perfectly
fine and correct
and then you just use your 117 as your
target
the interlab is a group is made out of
um sometimes hundreds of instruments
distributed across the world
and they can all have different reagent
loads or calibrator lots
and so they don't really reflect your
pure target but they are
different variations
so finally if we look at that crossover
then we can actually now see that this
is like a summary screen i made
to show you what you should do when
you're doing a new quality control
crossover
so you can see at the top we start with
our current lot that is in use
and so we have our mean or standard
deviation and our cv
and then 10 days before the end of that
lot
we're going to start measuring our new
law and we measure
one data point every day and once we get
to those 10 days
what we're then actually going to do is
from those 10 points we calculate
our new mean from or for our new lot so
we calculate our mean b here
and then we take the cv of the old lot
and with that cv we can now recalculate
the standard deviation
for the new lot and then we're ready to
go at day 10
we now have our new standard deviation
our new mean and we can start evaluating
those factors
remember that they're always an
estimation of our targets because we
only had limited amount of data here
so it's always interesting to
re-evaluate the mean and the standard
deviation
in the following months after we collect
more data to see
if it still reflects the actual
performance of the instrument
what can also be said is that if you're
using multiple instruments
if you're a bigger lab and you have four
or five instruments
and you use the same target on those
multiple instruments
then it is actually very good and
actually almost better
to also measure your new mean on those
different instruments
so what you would do for example is that
you could then run one quality control a
day
on four instruments for three days for
example and that will give you 12 data
points
and those 12 data points would be enough
to have your mean set
um just as a little tip always make sure
you measure at least two qc points per
instrument
just to avoid if there would be anything
going on and you would have
some strange results just make sure you
have two
uh points per instrument so you can
catch a flagrant outlier or something
like that
and as last couple of slides i just
quickly wanted to show you
if you use a qc data management software
like unity real time
how you practically can do a crossover
study in the software
so here you can see a duplicate lock
screen for unity real time
and that means that when you're running
into the end of a lot
you can actually tell the software okay
this is my new lot
you define it here the new lot number
and then you have an option in the
bottom
to copy the fixed standard deviation
over to the new law
and in our software it should actually
normally say fixed standard deviation
slash cv
because it copies over whatever you had
fixed either standard deviation
or cv so then when you do this
you will see now in your layout that you
actually have your two lots
in the software next to each other so
you have your old current load
and you have the new lot underneath and
when you then go
to your fixed mean and your standard
deviation
screen you can see in this new lot that
the mean is empty because we don't have
any data yet but you can see here that
for level one
the cv was copied over for level three
the sd was copied over and i just did
that as an example to show you that it
copies over whatever you had
set in the software the best one is like
we said
the level one is that we copy over the
cv
because then we don't have to worry
about the difference in absolute
values so when we go to the next screen
after our 10 data points were collected
we can now ask the software
to calculate from the floating
statistics to calculate our mean
and that mean is then applied and now
you can see that our table is completely
filled out we have a mean
and then we have a standard deviation
and a cv fixed
and we're ready to go with our new lot
of our quality control
if you want to visualize that you can
use a multiple levi jennings screen
you can see here on the top you see the
current lot
on the bottom you see the new lot that's
expressed
and that blue area shows us where we
were doing
our crossover study you also have an
option to put these two levi jennings
together into one chart and then here in
blue
you can see the crossover here i had to
change the colors a little
bit because otherwise it is a lot of
lines together
so here in blue and green you can see
the new lot
and then the other purple and orange was
our current plot
so like this you can nicely see that now
normally
we'll continue with those new lines with
the new lot and the old lot
is discontinued we stopped using them
so so far this was the presentation on
the quality control
crossovers and i'm going to hand it back
over
to susie for the second part of our
presentation
thank you
thank you nico for that informative
presentation we will now
start the second presentation of the
webinar which will discuss reagent lot
changes
in the lab i now present today's second
speaker mr
john pacheco mr yum pacheco performs
research
in quality control and patient risk
issues
for the informatics discovery group at
bio rad laboratories in plano texas
john has had the opportunity to
collaborate with laboratories
around the world developing practical
real-time
interlaboratory controls and proficiency
testing systems
as an innovator he has developed
numerous ideas
leading to over 35 laboratory related
inventive
patents around the globe all providing
new and cutting edge solutions for
diagnostic laboratories for complete
biography
of ms john pacheco please visit the
biography tab
at the top of your screen john welcome
you may now begin
your presentation sir
thank you susie i appreciate that
introduction
howdy um so
i'm here to talk about what do we have
to do
when we change reagent lot numbers
um and along the same lines that's
called the reagent crossover study
um unfortunately reagent crossovers
are a little bit more complicated than
when we do
a qc crossover and we'll talk about why
that is
but it it's a very very important
activity that you make sure when a new
reagent lot number is
introduced to your laboratory that
it it doesn't cause
problems one of the reasons for that is
actually you want to avoid unfortunate
circumstances
like what happened here in this news
article
where a new lot number of reagent
actually changed the behavior of the
test method
to the point where it was affecting the
the actual diagnosis of of patients
and this is just an example of how
critical it can be
when you change lot numbers you simply
have to make sure
that that that change
doesn't impact uh either the way that
your test method performs for patients
or the way that it uh it works for
controls
so um the bottom line is that
reagent systems are a critical part
of the test method and
usually as long as the the lots are
stored
according to uh to manufacture
specifications they're stable and two
until the expiration of the lot um
but when you have a new lot number it
needs to be evaluated to make sure that
there aren't any issues
that can affect the performance of
either
patient specimens or qc materials
and so that's why we do a reagent
crossover study
is to make sure that we've evaluated
you know any possible performance
changes
so um one thing that can happen
is a change that takes place
that affects the qc results but not the
patient results this is called the
matrix effect
and that's why we need to when we
when we change reagent lot numbers we
need to take a look at what's happening
with the patients
and specimens and we also need to take a
look at
what's happening with the qc
because we can have circumstances
where the patients only the patient
specimens are impacted or
only the qc specimens are both
and so when we design reagent crossover
studies
we have to take a look at what's
happening on the patient's specimen side
and what's happening on the qc side
so how do we do this well fortunately
um there is guidance that's available
and so what i'm going to be talking
about uh for the rest of my my
talk here is um how do we use
the clsi ep 26
reagent crossover studies it's user
evaluation of between
reagent lot variation so
this study describes in detail
exactly how do you design a
reagent crossover study and
that goes into what do we need to do to
ensure that
we are are comfortable with
any changes that would take place on the
performance
for patient specimens and
make sure that we are okay on the
performance of qc specimens
so
unlike what we have on the qc
side we have to actually design
a reagent crossover study
so it's a little bit more complicated
because
we have to go in and determine just
how many specimens how many samples do
we actually need to take a look at
you know as nico told us
when it comes to qc studies you can use
10 samples collected over 10 days
but that's not the that's not the case
when it comes to reagent crossover
studies
so what we need to do is take a look
at both patient and qc samples
that are evaluated um
with when we have the on both the old
and the new
system and so we
what we want to figure out is okay
how many specimens are needed and
how do we judge whether or not we're
going to accept the results
and that's what where we have the
guidance that's coming from
clsi
so fortunately
if somebody has done a reagent crossover
study
we can actually use their results
so unlike the the scenario when it comes
to
a qc crossover study that has to be done
for each laboratory but if we have an
affiliated laboratory
that has done a reagent crossover study
we can actually use their results and
we don't need to not take a look again
at
um at the patient sides we still do need
to take a look
at the qc side but at least we can reuse
um the results from somebody else that
has actually done a reagent crossover
study
for that specific law
so one of the things that we need to do
is determine exactly how much of the
change
can we tolerate this is this is called
the critical
difference and that tells us
um you know just what is the limit of
change that we're willing to accept
uh so it's it's kind of similar to uh
the total allowable error or equality
specification
and the critical difference values they
may come
from a number of different sources
like you know biological variation or
state of the art or x opinion
but part of what needs to happen is that
you need to determine
just how large of a shift would you
accept
with respect to the new and the old lot
number
this is called the critical difference
it's abbreviated as cd
well um
one of once you have the critical
difference so part of what you also have
to do
is you need to have
the the within laboratory imprecision
um which is abbreviated as sdwrl
and you need repeatability so
these are our values that you can obtain
from doing a precision study and
normally
once you do a precision study to
determine these types of values
you can use them from lot to lot
so we we
tend to attribute these values
as a characteristic of
the test method and so once you've
derived them you can reuse them
um and so both of these the the
uh within reagent lot standard deviation
and um the the within laboratory
imprecision
they are specific
but those need to be computed
before you can actually go in and do
um reagent crossover studies
so one way that you can
determine a critical difference is
using the biological variation approach
which is based on a reference change
value
and and so if you're familiar
with how to compute a reference change
value
you can do something very similar
using the the same approach except for
the critical difference
um you would use the within reagent lot
um standard deviation
and so that as an example here
you know if you have a if you've got
a uh a within
cv of 6 and a within reagent lot cv of
1.6
you can compute a critical difference as
17.2
so if we've got then
the critical difference and now we've
computed
just how much of a difference are we
willing to accept from one reagent lot
to the next
let's see how do we actually use that
well we need to determine what the
rejection limit
is going to be and in addition
to the critical um
the the in addition to the critical
difference
we also have this concept of
of taking a fraction of that critical
difference
and computing the reagent limit so it's
it creates the rejection limit
should be based on the clinical utility
of the test
so it's a little bit like the severity
of harm category
that comes to us from from
ep 23 and so if you have
a test that uses a low factor
like 0.6 or or actually it should be 0.5
um and then least critical tests can use
a higher factor
which will give you more of a range of
0.9
or 0.8 okay so let's take a look at how
we actually use these
oh sorry
so we in addition to determining
how large a critical difference we're
willing to accept
um we we're going to take that
information
and use it to also determine what number
of samples
are are going to be required and so
within ep 26 in the appendices
there are a set of tables that allow us
to
determine how many samples do we need
at each concentration and there's
there's three tables for a single
concentration
or two concentrations or three
concentrations
and so did based on determine
based on the number of concentrations
that you're using
that's going to determine which of the
appendices you need to use
to figure out how many samples
would you use and what what are you
going to
need for a given rejection limit so okay
let's take as an example uh
table a2 for two concentrations
now when you look at this um
we can first see that if we look at the
columns
there are the the first two columns here
are the critical difference
divided by the within reagent lot
standard deviation and then the second
the second table there
is the standard deviation
of the total the
within the laboratory standard deviation
divided by
the within reagent lot standard
deviation
so those are what we use to actually
index the row and then the other columns
are based on our
rejection limit so we're going to use
0.9.8.7
and so that's how we select which column
are we going to actually use so
let's take a quick look um
you need to actually compute those two
ratios
first where we've got again the ratio
of the critical change to analytical
precision
um and basically the uh
the higher that this is the lower
number of samples you're going to need
and then you've got the ratio
of your standard deviation
within the laboratory divided by the
within
reagent lot standard deviation
so that's really that's a
a ratio of repeatability to analytical
precision
and the smaller that that is
um the higher the number of samples that
you're going to need
so we use that combination is what's
used
to index the row that you're going to
use
within that within that appendix
okay so the way that we do this
is you first find a section that
matches your cd to swrl ratio
and then when if you have a value that's
between
two values you're going to use the next
lowest
value and then you find the row
that matches your sr to swrl
value and and you
once you've got that then you go across
to find the column that corresponds with
your rejection limit
so the number outside the parenthesis
is the number of samples required um the
first number inside
the parenthesis is the the probability
of a false
rejection a false positive result
and then the second is the probability
of error detection
so let's take a quick look let me just
so um let's
let's see how we actually use this all
right so in this example
um i'm using an example based on ast
with two sample concentrations um
we've got 40 and 200
and you can see the corresponding
critical differences
and here we have the uh
the different the critical difference
and the swrl
and the the sr
and we've decided that for this analyte
we're going to use a rejection criteria
of 0.7 and then we've gone on ahead and
we've computed
the ratios that we need to use in order
to actually
find within the table
just how many samples do we need
so let's look at what that looks like
okay now this is
a little hard to see but
if you take a look here the ratios that
we're looking for
are 7.7 and 0.62
and so when we look this up
um we're going to go one down
so that puts us that puts us
in for the first one so this is a
section
of the table then we look at 0.62
and where so that gives us the row of
0.6
and then we select the column that's
telling us
okay what is the experiment design that
we need
and it's telling us that in this case we
need just one sample
now the samples that we're talking about
here are the patient samples
so for the design of this crossover
study
for ast we would need one
sample that's going to be near 40.
[Music]
and then we would do the same thing on
our second concentration so in this case
at for 200 we go through the same
process
and we at 4.9
we find the one that's next down which
is 4.5
and then with our with our
sr to swrl ratio it's
0.32 so one down from that is going to
be 0.3
so we basically round down when we're
trying to determine exactly which row to
use
and in this case it's telling us that we
need two samples
near 200. so that then
gives us um
the rea the sample design
okay and then this is what
now that we know that we've got we're
gonna need two specimens
uh for the the higher concentration and
one specimen for the
the lower concentration this is what
that might look like
so we can see that the current
lot result um we have 62
at the for the lower concentration
and then with the the new reagent lot
that we're looking at
it's 62.6 and so
the difference between those is 0.6
and in this case you know we want to
actually take a look at what's the
average
difference and it's 0.6
then we can do the same thing on the
the higher concentration where now in
this case we're using
two samples and with those two samples
when we do the same thing we see that we
have a difference of
minus 1.4 and minus 11.
so when we average those the average
just
difference is minus 6.25
well our rejection limits are 7
and 14. so our
differences are less than the rejection
limits
and so we're going to go ahead and
accept those
and so this is um how you
you design the study that you're gonna
use
and uh once you have done this type of a
study
once you've done the the design of the
study
you can use this over and over again
so while it does take some initial work
to design this type of study once it's
done for your test system and
ideally this is done uh
when you adopt uh the the test the test
system so when you're doing the
validation
of your test method you want to
do a this design at the same time
um but if that didn't take place well
then you you need to do the design and
what you have to design
you can use it over and over again the
only thing that you may need to
when you may need to revisit it is if
you have
issues with trying to locate patient
samples that are going to be in the
concentration range
that the study is designed for
so all of this is coming from clsi
document ep 26
and that is what i would recommend that
you take a look at
for determining how to do reagent
crossover studies
thank you very much
thank you john for that great
presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have any questions you'd
like to ask either nico or john
please do so now just click on that ask
a question box located on the far
left of your screen so let's get started
gentlemen it looks like we already have
some great questions
coming in addressed for both of you so
our first question
goes to you john our audience member
says
do i really need to use patient
specimens
for a reagent crossover study
yes you do and the reason for that
is that uh you know as i as i noted in
my presentation
there is this possible matrix effect
where the qc specimens can sometimes
behave
differently than patient specimens
and so you do actually need to take a
look and confirm
that what is the the performance with
respect to patient specimens
and unfortunately you know
we've had reports from labs that
you know if you simply rely on only qc
results they you can have shifts when it
comes to
the patient means um that
are caused by a new reagent lot number
that you might not detect
just from qc alone and so because of
that
you do need to actually look at both qc
and patient specimens
thank you so much john our next question
is for you nico
how often do i need to check my mean and
sd values
if they're still appropriate
okay so after our crossover when we
initially set our targets
then i would wait until we have
something like at least
60 to like 90 data points uh before we
would look at them again
and and then we can evaluate if our
targets are still
uh appropriate if something would have
shifted a bit up for your target for
example those are things you can then
evaluate
throughout the life of the control it is
something which you would probably do
like in your monthly review and i really
like using
uh the levi jennings chart for that
because you can clearly see
if your results start trending upwards
or trending downwards
if that would need a change it's also
important to see if you can
rather fix it first with for example a
calibration or with maintenance
then just continuously changing your
targets that is also another
the best practice but normally you
wouldn't check
more than once a month to see if
something
is behaving differently also remember
that yeah the most critical points are
reagent block changes
or calibrated law changes things like
that that can have an effect on on your
targets
thank you so much nico and i want to
thank our audience for these great
questions
coming in we'll move back to you john
should we also establish new means for
each
different qc or reagent shipment
so what you need to do is take a look to
see
if uh if you're other if that's
necessary
so reagent lots a new reagent lot
may or may not require you to change
means
and what you need to do is simply
evaluate
your qc materials on the new lot number
and take a look to see if you know how
different are they
from the old lot number and if they're
very different
then you need to basically do the same
approach basic do another
uh qc crossover uh if
if there is a significant difference in
the performance
thank you so much now nico an audience
member wants to know
can i establish my mean value in
multiple measurements
on the same day yes good question
you you can if if you would want to if
it's really necessary
um with this new guidance of clsi
with just using 10 data points in 10
different days
it already shortens or crossover study
if you really don't
have enough material to to last those 10
days for example and you need to go
faster you can
just remember that if you go faster and
you do multiple
measurements in one day there could be a
bit less variation
in those results so you could have a bit
more
uh you could see it a little later for
example so it
it's it's you can do it but just make
sure that after a longer period of time
you re-evaluate and you look at it
thank you nico and here's a follow-up
question about outliers
do i have to remove outliers from my
crossover period
so i think i mentioned this in the
presentation so we would always look at
our current uh quality control to see if
there is something out of control or
there is a problem then we will remove
that result
from the crossover study but it could
happen
that you have maybe a random error or
an outlier just in your new lot when
you're doing your crossover study that
didn't happen in the other one so if you
would see a clear and flagrant
outlier in those 10 data points in your
crossover
you could remove it and add an
additional data point
so you could take a look normally the
chance is smaller to have something like
that
but if it happens you could actually
remove it yes
thank you so much nico we have time for
just one more question
john this one's for you how can i tell
if there has been a change in
performance with my new lot of rea
agents well
that's actually what we have to do here
is that the way we can tell
if there is a change um and really
what we're concerned about is not just
whether or not there's a change
what we're concerned about is is there a
change
that is large enough that it's going to
impact
the the way that we use test results
for our patients and so it's a critical
change
that that we're trying to detect and and
the way that we do that
is with this uh reagent crossover study
design
so we need to take the
the number of samples that our design is
requiring
us to use um and we're going to take
patient samples run them on the current
lot number
and run them on the candidate lot number
and then look at those differences and
see if those differences
are acceptable or not um and so
we really want to do that before we
actually start
using the new lot number of reagents
because if we don't do that check then
we are going to introduce
those changes without
without realizing that that that's
happened
and and that can be that can present
a a dangerous set of circumstances for
the laboratory
um and in particular it it can
potentially have a negative impact on
on our patients and so that's why we
actually have to do
this reagent crossover um
when you have a new lot number if
somebody else
that has not done that study
gentlemen i want to thank you again for
your time today and i want to thank you
for your important research
and before we go i want to thank our
audience for joining us
today and for their interesting
questions questions we did not have time
for today
will be addressed by our speakers and
posted in the event
resources by the end of next week and
this webcast
will be available on demand in the
auditorium from friday on
if you found this information helpful
please share it with colleagues for the
next webinar on april
7th we will have a panel discussion
where you can ask
all of your questions about quality
control
four qc experts will be our panelists
and they will answer your qc questions
please stay tuned and watch
your email inbox for the invitation and
you will also be able to submit your
questions up front
to the panel until next time stay safe
and stay healthy
thank you and bye